for secure and efficient data
transmission over the network channel
control mechanisms are needed to govern
the transmission of data
which will be our topic for today's
session
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
in today's session we will look into
what is stop and wait protocol
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to miss an update from
us
now without further ado let's take a
look at the agenda for today's session
for today's session
to begin with we will look into
introduction to the stop and wait
protocol
moving forward with steps involved in
the protocol
and continuing with the working of the
stop-inward protocol
and ending our session with knowing some
drawbacks of applying stop-ended
protocol
now let's move on to the first heading
that is introduction to the protocol
the stop and rate protocol is a type of
flow control mechanism active in the osi
model of the data link layer
the transmission of data applies only to
the noiseless channels
where a noiseless channel represents an
ideal network channel where no frames
are lost duplicated or hacked
moving on we have
the stop and rate protocol is
unidirectional in transmission of data
that is
either sending or receiving data will
only takes place at an instance
for the third point we have
the stop and rate protocol as the name
suggests is when the sender shares a
data packet to the receiver end then the
sender side has to stop and wait for the
receiver side to send an acknowledgement
before it starts sending the next data
packet
with this point we are now knowledgeable
about the working of the stop and
protocol at an elementary level
now let's move on to the next heading
the next heading for the session is
steps involved in the stop and wait
protocol
the steps for this protocol are divided
into two parts sender and receiver
protocol
let's start with the sender side
the first step is to transmit one data
unit at a time to the receiver end by
the sender side
and the next step is
to transmit the next data until only
after we receive the acknowledgement
from the receiver end
now let's move on to the receiver side
in receiver side step one is to receive
the data and use the data that is being
sent
then the second step is after the data
has been used by the receiver side it
will send the acknowledgement to the
sender side for further data
transmission
this is how the transmission of data
takes place in the data protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is working of stop and rate
protocol
using the previous two headings we can
easily determine the steps involved in
this working
let's take a look
to begin with we have two sides the
sender and the receiver side
the first step is
to send the data from the sender side to
the receiver end
and after the receiver side has used the
data it will send the acknowledgement
signal
meanwhile the sender side has to wait
for the acknowledgement signal
only after it receives the
acknowledgement signal will it send the
next data packet
now that the sender side has sent the
data for the second time
the receiver site will use this data and
then only share the acknowledgement
signal
this process of sending data from the
sender side to the receiver side and
receiving acknowledgement from the
receiver side to the sender side
continues
for n number of times
according to the given scenario in the
network channel
now let's move on to the next heading
that is also the last heading for this
session that is drawbacks of using
stop and read protocol
the first drawback of using this
protocol is the loss of data
this issue can arise when transmitting
data from the sender side to the
receiver end
it may be due to any issue due to
hacking attempt or network disruption
or any other network related issue
then
this can also arise when receiving
acknowledgement from the receiver site
now let's move on to the second drawback
the next issue is related to
acknowledgement transmission that is
during the transmission of
acknowledgement signal
due to the network issues
the acknowledgement signal is disrupted
and the transmission is terminated
this can arise again due to any reasons
that are occurring in the network
channel
now let's move on to the last drawback
for this heading
the last issue occurs due to the delay
in transmission time of the information
time delay drawback can occur on either
side of the transmission that is during
data transmission
or the acknowledgement transmission
with the completion of the drawbacks we
are completed with the session on stop
and rate protocol but stay tuned this
topic is not yet finished
we'll come up with the next video that
is sliding window protocol which is in
continuation with stop and wait protocol
so stay tuned with this we have reached
the end of the video if you have any
questions regarding the topic you can
ask them in the comment section below
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here